Tatyana Heidler is an equestrian the
most important event on her calendar
this year is coming up the Special
Olympics it's a week-long sports
tournament for people with intellectual
disabilities taking place in Kiel in
northern Germany over 4,000 athletes are
participating the stakes are high for
Tatiana she spent months training going
home without a medal simply isn't an
option for the 28 year old
clucky an arai blur is in kiel for the
Special Olympics taking part for the
fifth time she's here with her sister
Munya a successful equestrian her
intellectual disability is described by
doctors as partly impaired consciousness
tatyana herself describes it as a
difficulty in grasping time and place
her family believe it's a consequence of
antiepileptic drug she was given at the
age of three if you said let's meet
somewhere in an hour I know that means I
have an hour of time but I don't really
know what that feels like
people might say oh you could do this or
that before we meet and I'd go do I have
time is there enough time it's a
disability that people don't necessarily
notice straightaway sometimes they don't
believe I really have a problem they
think I'm joking I've actually
experienced that I always say I'm not
joking that they might not be able to
tell but I have serious issues the fact
that you can't necessarily tell can be a
disadvantage tatyana has been training
for ten years she probably spends more
time with her horse and chachi than with
anyone else she doesn't ask questions
she doesn't judge animals are honest
which is something you can't always say
for humans the first event is about to
begin dressage Tatiana is in the
advanced category she's up against some
tough competition
Tatiana's sister Manya runs her through
the tests with a working trot working
trot medium trot it all goes well time
to gallop all the way around they've
been training for so long but today of
all days and chachi refuses to gallop
properly
Tatiana will lose vital points
regardless Manya is pleased with
Tatiana's performance apart from the
gallop which didn't work they only
managed a few jumps right at the end but
it was really good
Baskins food well what disaster
you're in trouble
jumping this afternoon hopefully she'll
do it we've practiced so much it worked
before but okay that wasn't brilliant
not great the other contestants are in
high spirits winning isn't everything at
the Special Olympics everyone's allowed
on the podium
[Music]
the proximity receipt
tatyana write them in short eat the
vectors X comma noise
[Applause]
[Music]
you weren't expecting that were you I
[Music]
wasn't expecting it I couldn't really
tell how I done
we didn't hear what the judges had given
us so I was really excited to find out
how I was placed disappointing sure
you're not disappointed after that round
she'll be satisfied with a silver or a
bronze but she wouldn't say no to a gold
either we're working on it there are
still a number of categories where
tatianna could win her long four gold
medal she already has a few at home but
before the next event she has a look
around
to see what the other athletes are doing
she watches the judo for a while
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
along with the competitive events the
Special Olympics also hosts fun
activities that help the athletes unwind
like stand-up paddleboarding cloudy
arrival alook saunas her daughter takes
to the water she's proud of her Tatyana
has a job as an assistant gardener in a
workshop for disabled people but she
needs a lot of help with daily chores
such as buying groceries cooking and
running errands Tatyana relies on her
mother and sister her mother gave up her
job as a teacher to help look after
Tatiana it wouldn't be a good idea to do
everything for her because there might
be times when I can't
oh I'm no longer in a position to but
Manya shouldn't have to do everything
for her either she shouldn't have to
manage everything alone but it's all
okay
Tatiana is strong enough and able to
cope with life by herself her own way
laughing back in the stable and Choji
needs to be fed the next event will be
taking place in a few hours the horse
jumping event this is the one that
Tatiana is most nervous about I can get
confused by which jump comes after which
I have to make sure I don't lose my
sense of direction in the obstacle
course the route is only announced at
the last minute
Tatiana doesn't have much time to take
it in we need to go round the little
house then the bench then around the
corner okay
this is her biggest challenge when all
the months of training have been leading
up to she can't lose her focus now
apart from one small error she gets off
to a smooth start
but then intro Qi decides to dig in her
heels she refuses to clear the hurdle
second attempt the same thing happens
Tatiana
isn't giving up she tries again
but the judges don't award her any
points she won't be getting the medal
everyone's a bit sad Tatyana wanted it
to work
it wasn't necessarily about coming first
but about the actual performance about
getting the sequence right not even
words of comfort from fellow athletes
can cheer her up I'm glad she cleared
the last hurdle you can't just leave it
out I don't know what the problem was
she just didn't feel like it the day
ends with an appearance as Peter Pan the
whole team is involved as well as a
horse woman who's not part of the
Special Olympics it looks like a bit of
fun but more medals are awarded at the
end of the show nothing escaped the
judges eagle eyes
[Music]
all the competing athletes are hoping to
qualify for the International Special
Olympics at Abu Dhabi next year for
Tatiana it would be a dream come true
I'm applying to be a spokesperson for
the international event that's one of my
goals for the future
another bronze medal
if Tatiana is disappointed she's not
showing it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
taking part has been a boost to
Tatiana's self-confidence successes like
these helped her cope better with
everyday life and her family's proud of
her
with or without a gold medal
[Applause]